make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys to the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into Secret Wars
too here's the cool thing this story is
only nine issues along and technically
we can cover it in two parts right it's
nowhere near as complex as Secret Wars
one the interesting thing about this is
depending on who you talk to some people
will say they hated Secret Wars two
other people will say it was amazing
it's so pretty well from what I
understand so I enjoyed it like I enjoy
the second half of it the first half is
kind of like alright but the second half
is when you get like the cosmic entities
and all that kind of crazy stuff which
gets really really cool but nonetheless
picking up with this again this really
kind of comes hot off the heels not not
immediately but it comes off the heels
of the the first Secret Wars comic right
so we're talking about the idea that at
the end of the first Secret Wars the
idea of the Beyonder was never fully
reconciled in the sense that we never
really knew what it was we simply just
knew it was just this entity that was
like I am from beyond and that was
basically it but because the the story
sold so well indicating people liked it
otherwise people wouldn't have bought it
because you know people don't buy
stories they don't like the result is
that Marvel continued the song into a
second comic now this one really picks
up with Owen Reese and Marsha now if
those the guys who saw Secret Wars one
you'll recall those two why they kind of
have that that story really focus on
their relationship and ultimately Owen
Reese ended up moving in with Marsha in
Denver Colorado right so that is kind of
relaxing and chilling and doing their
thing when there's like this huge you
know kind of explosion sound from off in
the distance now the funny thing about
this is that you know and Reese is like
I don't know maybe it was a truck that
backfired or something like that and
it's like okay look Owen if that was a
truck that backfired you see the biggest
truck in the history of the world or it
exploded because like it's pretty far
away and it's a pretty loud noise but at
that point the entire TV starts going on
the fritz the signals lost all kinds of
crazy things are going on and when they
stick their head out and they start
looking at what's going on suddenly like
all these trees and huge chunks of rocks
and everything are all flying in a
direction now Marsha is able to destroy
one of the boulders but a response Owen
Reese of course uses his powers to kind
of you know really kind of seem try to
control the situation but what he ends
up realizing is that on one of these
chunks of rock is a guy out there right
just some guy sitting on this rock and
Owen Reese begins to pick up on the
energy signature and realizes it's the
Beyonder now when that happens we
immediately switch over to Charles
Xavier
there's a couple things that I want to
talk about here I'm really one big thing
that I want to discuss the first thing
is that this comes before uncanny x-men
issue number 200 right so at this point
in time Charles Xavier is still here on
earth and magneto has not taken over
leadership of the x-men or the new
mutants but he's on his way
taking over that role that's the reason
why when you actually see magneto in
this story he'll have that outfit with a
great big huge M on it and it'll look
like the cover of uncanny x-men where
he's standing there in handcuffs
handcuffs on his on his hands and on his
feet where he's basically going to stand
trial right the trial of magneto is what
that story was called that's why it
looks so familiar here but the other
part of this is that on the x-men roster
is Rachel summers now the idea of Rachel
summers for those who guys who are
familiar with her character bear with me
for a second this is not a huge talking
point but she is going to be more or
less the field commander of the team at
least in this particular instance given
the power that she possesses but the
reason why this matters is Rachel
summers made her debut in Days of Future
Passed right you guys have all pretty
much heard of that story and she was
essentially the only instance in any
alternate reality where we've ever seen
Scott Summers or Cyclops in Jean Grey
have a child and it turned out to be a
girl right in every other alternate
reality it's a guy it's basically Nate
Nate grey or Nate Summers whatever you
want to call him Rachel's the only
exception to that at least that I know
of
the result is that during Days of Future
past of course she said the mind of
Kitty Pryde into the past to stop the
assassination of Charles Xavier more
McTaggart and Senator Robert Kelly in
order to prevent Days of Future past him
happening the result is that it didn't
quite work out that way and so what
ended up happening is that while Days of
Future past was stopped the future that
Rachel came from became an alternate
reality and so what she ended up doing
was basically travelling back into the
past and really kind of arriving in the
modern day now this takes place in a few
different stories it's really kind of
spread over days of future present from
the 1990s excalibur number 52 and
uncanny x-men number 199 now uncanny
x-men 199 is really words it's kind of
like he or she is now but the idea is
that she kind of has a fraction of the
Phoenix forces powers up which she
attained from the Days of Future Passed
timeline right she basically got it from
that at that point and then jump back to
the modern day but that's why she's
essentially here now right now he's a
future president focuses more on
Franklin that alternate reality is
really the spiritual essence of Franklin
Richards from Days of Future past
showing up and then you know all kinds
of crazy stuff happening but that's more
or less how rachel gets here but over
the course of those three stories and
some ancillary stories in between it's
all kind of fleshed out right but that's
basically why she's here you can kind of
take that and run with it you know and
just just sort of sort of go with it but
at the end of the day what Xavier does
before he kind of passes out from the
mental strain is basically soon this
kind of telepathic message out to a
whole bunch of the different Avengers
right Captain America a magneto a few
others you know basically say the
Beyonder is back now when the beyonders
arrived here on earth and he's in
western America now
from that point it basically switches
back over to Owen this is where things
get kind of cool is because when the
Beyonder arrives here he's actually in
amalgamated of a bunch of different
characters right he's an amalgamation of
kind of like Ben Graham and dr. doom and
Cyclops and ulysses klaw and so on and
so forth and he basically just like he
literally it looks like a 1980s wrestler
more or less like the WUF in the 1980s
like here comes the Beyonder with dink
and doink you know who's gonna win the
pageant but uh but that's kind of how it
looks but but notice this any symbols of
humanity is essentially removed now
that's something that I want you to
focus on because that was one of the
cool aspects of Secret Wars 2 is the
Beyonder progressively becomes more
human over the course of the story but
all he basically says is I desire to
understand now Owen Reese is aware of
who the Beyonder is right like what he's
capable of so he doesn't really need a
whole lot of explanation here but the
overall reason for why the beyonders
doing this or why he's here is because
remember like in the first secret Wars
he looked at humanity right he looked at
the overall gist of humanity and
basically said that there is essentially
incompleteness there now this
incompleteness is a result of people
right like the nature of human beings in
the sense that in the beyond diverse at
the time this story was written the
Beyonder was essentially his entire
universe right so there was nothing but
him whereas here you've got all
different kinds of organisms and people
and races and things like that you've
got political conflicts and you've got
different ideologies and so on and so
forth but everybody's looking to
understand the meaning of life which is
really what the Beyonder is asking here
and so the result is that owners like
man I can't really answer that question
I can't really answer the question of
what the meaning of life is instead he
gives them a little bit of guidance and
it's really more just kind of get him
out of his hair and he's like the only
way to really understand them the the
meaning of life is to gain experience to
go out there and experience things and
then kind of figure it out for yourself
right into a degree that's true well you
know confidence comes with experience
understanding the world it comes with
experience but you've got to get out
there you got to try things and you got
to see what kind of works for you what
doesn't and then just go from there and
so what the beyond are basically taking
off of course Marsha asked the question
is everything gonna be okay and Owens
like yeah man he'll be fine he's just
some omnipotent being that doesn't
understand humanity and he's just kind
of floating out there in the world
what's the worst that could happen
but from there you basically pick up
with the x-men more or less meeting up
with magneto right now this is kind of a
skirmish that sort of pops off it's on a
great big huge thing it's like one page
more or less but essentially Colossus
comes to the rescue and it's like hey
look Magneto's here to talk right easier
to talk to us
really here to initiate a conflict or
anything like that everything's cool
chill out guys like it's all gonna be
alright so of course they're not
grabbing a vehicle and then traveling
out to Hollywood where they're beyond a
resides now one thing to understand is
that Rachel summers is kind of the
connection there right she can pick up
on where they're beyonders at because of
her telepathic powers but she's by no
means on par with the beyond right she
doesn't relie have the same kind of
power that he does instead what you end
up getting is basically the Beyonder
showing up in Los Angeles and then
coming across a guy by the name of
Stewart cadwal now this is kind of
important here because the be honor
doesn't really understand the notion of
good and evil right it doesn't he's a
really understand what good is what evil
is he has understand human desire he
doesn't understand things like being
taken advantage of or anything along
those lines I said when when he
basically displays his power to steward
and turning like his office and
everything into like just a whole bunch
of apples release his desk and
everything into a whole bunch of apples
then it's her and Stewart picks up on
the idea of this guy can do anything so
he basically says give me a fraction of
your power and then what kind of go from
there
and so what is up happening is the
Beyonder bestows a fraction of its power
on to Stewart and Stewart goes forward
as like this this guy named Thunder
sword now this is where things get a
little murky because you would think the
Beyonder would have learned his lesson
from the first secret wars but stowing
his power onto somebody and how awful it
can go awry we've kind of seen how that
can play out and how negative that can
be especially with dr. doom having
stolen his power in the first place so
Alyssa the Beyonder hasn't learned
anything from his first and first
experience with humanity in the various
superheroes but what the students up
doing is it basically leads to Stewart
kind of going forward as Thunder Lord
and trying to like make the world a
better place but ultimately causing more
problems than anything else attacking
various places and any any ideology that
he doesn't agree with he ends up
attacking right so it's like Twitter
basically and the result is that when
this happens of course the x-men who
were hot on the trail of the Beyonder
stumble across this great big huge
conflict and then basically try to track
down thunder Lord and defeat him and at
the same time the Avengers respond as
well so it's not particularly
interesting and it's not really really
fascinating what is kind of important
here is what goes on behind the scenes
and this will be a common theme that you
will see with regards to the first you
know really this video is like something
will be happening and then the Beyonder
will just pop up and the reason for that
is because unlike the first Secret Wars
which was entirely self-contained it was
just a twelve issued limited series and
you didn't really have to read anything
else because it took place out in you
know out in space on battle world with
Secret Wars - it actually ties into
ongoing comp try and we'll talk about
that you know as we kind of get through
this you won't go
the individual comics themselves what
kind of talk about that to a degree but
what is up happening is that while
thunderlord's kind of running amok and
doing his whole thing you basically have
the Beyonder who appears to to Rachel
summers and then to Illyana Rasputin and
when he does he basically takes the
Darkchild concept of Illyana Rasputin
where she gives in to this kind of inner
evil and then just grabs her like
literally Caesar forces the Darkchild
person on personality to manifest and
then in turn the dark child whisks them
away to limbo right so it's kind of a
way to sort of remove the x-men
temporarily to kind of follow up in
their own individual comic and then of
course they end up returning here but
Wolverine basically lashes out kind of
goes into a berserker rage believing
that the Beyonder who basically killed
them and when that happens what is up
going on as a beyonder of course slashed
all the pieces and bleeding all over the
place is perfectly fine and then
basically the x-men are just kind of
made to vanish right there's sort of
like okay you're out of here now
understand the Beyonder is not doing
this because it's like I feel like doing
evil things because I saw a really mean
TV show and I'm just copying what I saw
that's not the case for him there he's
just doing things right like for him
it's no different than breathing or
anything like that
but what he's doing is experimenting and
learning that's essentially what's
happening here right so it's no
different than a baby coming to the
realization that if it cries it will get
attention a baby can't say my diaper
needs to be changed the baby just cries
and then the parents come to it and then
basically you know solve whatever is
ailing that baby at that point in time
no of course thunder Lord is more or
less taken out you know pretty quickly
in the sense of it's like okay you know
his his powers are basically drained and
the molecule man just sort of leaves him
there and walks away but in response
that where he sort of vanishes you know
Captain America tries to confront him
and he kind of vanishes instead kind of
facsimile of the Beyonder in an
invisible form follows Captain America
around just to see what's going on but
at the same time he also teleports his
main self directly to the city of New
York and then actually ends up in San
Francisco and then just starts looking
around and in like taking a look at
people and just sort of seeing what's
going on
and what you get is this sort of run
over about different things that are
taking place in the various comics right
like this coincides around within about
a month or two a Fantastic Four issue
number 280 those are guys who understand
that who know that reference you get the
significance of it for those guys who
don't that's basically the beginning of
the malleus saga where Susan storm
becomes malice is about three or four
issues long but she becomes like this
totally evil version of herself more or
less but what's also going on here and
this is kind of an on running theme in
the the Fantastic Four stories up to
this point is you basically have
psycho-man now psycho-man is not
particularly important he's not very
interesting at all he's a character
that's been around for a long time right
since about 1967 and he actually comes
from the Microverse right the
microscopic universe inside the main
marvel universe in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they called the quantum realm
as basically what it is but it's all
essentially the same thing they call it
that because Marvel doesn't have the
legal rights to use the Microverse
outside of the comics as far as I'm
aware but essentially psycho-man and
then you've also got hatemonger it's
weird ah they're basically kind of going
through and just instilling hate you
know every breeze every place they go
manipulating the emotions of people and
driving them into conflict against
superheroes but ultimately you end up
having psycho man I just really hate
monger and psycho man using their mecha
nations to turn Susan storm into malice
and that kind of continues on in the
actual Fantastic Four to 82 to 83 but
what you also have going on here if
somebody grabs a brick throws it through
the window of a department building and
the Beyonder walks in and as this guy
walks up and it's just like did you
throw the brick through the window and
you know why are you working in here the
response to the Beyonder is I just
desire to learn right I decide it's a
desire to understand most of the guys
like look I don't know who you are or
what's going on but it's kind of weird
that your dress on and white with no
shoes on but maybe you should go find a
friend and so at the end of the day the
Dioner is like okay yes I will do that I
will go find a friend and then
ultimately seeks out Peter Parker now
Peter Parker doesn't realize it's the
Beyonder in the beyond or doesn't tell
him who he is now it's really more
because of the fact that it doesn't dawn
on him to introduce himself he's just
kind of like I am from beyond you know
or something along those lines but
ultimately it gets kind of crazy because
the Beyonder looks at Peter Parker and
sees that when he's just Peter that
people just kind of treat him like a
normal person but when he puts on the
spider-man costume suddenly everybody is
like oh my god it's spider-man mystery
starts asking things like you know why
do people eat you know why do people do
these kinds of things right having
watched what people do watch how they in
turn have they interact in their
everyday lives it's why do people eat
like why do people sleep like why do
people desire things like like why do
you do what you do
I just wholly new to humanity with no no
real clue here and the response of Peter
is man I don't really know I mean we do
it just because we do it you know but
like people people respond to me
differently when I'm spider-man because
one they don't know I'm spider-man and
to spider-man is a hero and they kind of
they kind of cherish that and better the
same time he's like look if what you're
looking to understand is essentially the
meaning of life and all that you need to
go talk to Reed Richards right because
he's super smart and around that time
the Beyonder has to go to the bathroom
for the first time so Peter Parker's
like just go right in there man just
don't blow it up
make sure you spray dude and so at that
moment what you do is you basically
switch over to the Fantastic Four kind
of in the midst of this whole conflict
we're really kind of the aftermath of
this conflict with malice and then in
turn like you know the Beyonder shows up
to Reed Richards and it's just kind of
like you know I desire to understand
things like I desire to know things now
Reed it doesn't really panic the way you
would expect him to well you kind of
look at reiden you're kind of like okay
so this guy would be like oh my god the
beyonders here you know and kind of
start to freak out but how many more or
less been warned of what was coming
about Captain America and and so on then
he basically says okay you know I would
love to teach you and explain to you but
I don't know if I can fully explain like
the intricacies of the universe to you
mess to the Beyonder is like okay that's
enough gone and he basically takes off
then he basically ends up bailing out
from that point he ends up you know
coming across some kind of a you know a
suit inside a department store and
basically takes a suit puts it on
himself
and then he runs into an old homeless
woman and this is one of the coolest
things right because she's just sort of
like okay look you've won you can't
steal stuff from people like that so she
kind of starts to provide these sort of
societal guidelines on what a person can
I can't do and then to she's kind of
like if you're gonna do this like you
got to make yourself look presentable
right I mean you gotta wear shoes and
different things along those lines you
know and it's kind of funny because he's
like well how does like why do people do
what they do like like how do things
work here and she basically says like
like money is essentially the one thing
that matters most in this world right
it's the one thing that people prize
above pretty much everything else and
it's what makes the world go round right
like the only way you can really get
anywhere in this world is to have money
right and then you kind of ask the
question like you know the the small
little creatures you know who share your
clothing they pay for their shelter
she's like what the bugs no they don't
pay for shelter the Flies are free but
it's kind of crazy because what they
beyond their experiences for the first
time is being mugged right in the others
these guys show up that basically think
that that he's super wealthy and instead
of helping them understand their place
in the bigger picture or like why be
them out of existence or something like
that he's just kind of like you know for
him it doesn't really matter right
because I'm he's super omnipotent
insanely powerful if he fixes itself
like that you know and that's basically
it but then from there she basically
pulls out a card and says here's Heroes
for Hire you should go look into them
you know maybe they can give you some
kind of experience or something like
that and of course he ends up jumping
there now this is what you start to get
these interesting displays of the
beyonders power right because it's one
thing to heal yourself we've seen Wolfe
reign do that all the time we see
Deadpool do that not bad at the time the
story's written Deadpool doesn't exist
but once he does pop up you see Deadpool
heal himself you see that kind of thing
all the time one of the cool displays
that goes on here is that Wiggy shows
up in the office of Heroes for Hire he
realizes that Luke Cage and Iron Fist
were here but they're currently not here
right now
so what he does is he snatches them out
of time and brings them to this current
location and then a fight breaks out
Luke Cage is like I'm gonna kill this
man I'll beat this man with an inch of
his life you know and they they both do
kind of get into a conflict with each
other but Danny ran ends up being the
one to kind of jump in and try to talk
reason here but it's a funny thing
because Danny Rams like look man if
you're looking for experience man like I
can help you kind of get the experience
you're looking for I can direct you
where you need to go essentially just
kind of like building yourself a girl
man and you'll you'll experience a lot
if you do that but ultimately Luke Cage
is one that kind of comes in and says
the same thing that the old homeless
woman said money is what matters in this
world money is what gets you the the
services of Heroes for Hire money is
what gets you a place to live is what
gets you food all that kind of stuff
somebody's always got a pig right that's
kind of way that worse and so ultimately
the Beyonder walks up to the building of
Luke Cage and one of the coolest
displays of power and then
rematerialized is the whole thing and
turns the whole building into gold now
of course it is up collapsing under its
own weight
but it's a cool sight to see the
beyonders like I had your services you
help me with something therefore I have
to pay so I turn this building into gold
right again just kind of doing things
that seem to be arbitrary I understand
this is how the world is supposed to
work therefore I'm going to conduct
myself in this way and so what you end
up doing is running into probably one of
the more interesting aspects of the
story when the Beyonder gets hookers
right because what he is up doing is
making his way you know down the road
and then comes across this this one
hooker who's just kind of standing there
and like she's a sort of like hey are
you looking for some kind of company or
something like that he's like I mean I
guess you know like I am from beyond you
know I I guess that's what I'm looking
for like I just seek to understand no
she's like well you got to give us some
money first so he produces a bar gold in
his hand and then she kind of freaks out
right she's like do this there's no way
that's real that's got to be fake so
she's like you need to go to like some
kind of a hotel and just chill right so
he ends up going like this super seedy
hotel right like the seediest of seedy
hotels and then when that happens like
he's basically confronted by tutsi who
is this chick about us is what they
refer to harassed by her pimp and then
the guy who runs the whole show and what
he basically says is hey look man like
our friend introduced us and showed us
this bar of gold that you've created so
like let's talk you only listen let's
converse and let's let's hang out with
each other and so basically this guy mr.
Corvo leaves the Beyonder in the
presence of Tut's you know basically
this hooker and in the next morning she
takes him around town and starts to show
him all these different things right to
help
understand what it means to eat right to
understand food different things like
that why people do what they do and it's
kind of funny because he initially goes
to get a drink and just goes to eat the
whole thing and she's like no no don't
do that like whatever you eat just like
eat the food off the fork but don't eat
the fork the funny thing is that Corvo
comes along and breathes like a whole
bunch of girls right something like like
how many girls are here one two three
four five six chicks right six chicks
and Twitter's like dude I could have
taught in this whole thing by himself
right like the guy needs experience I
could have given him the experience you
know but like at the end of the day mr.
Korbell I was like yeah but like with
six girls he's gonna get more experience
right because like six different smiles
so it's like okay and then like or bone
starts doing these these things that are
kind of questionable but not terrible I
mean he's using the Beyonder to produce
like huge amounts of gold to intimidate
opposition different things like that
but then it's also stuff to like cure
his son's dyslexia and probably one of
the crappiest things to make his wife
look beautiful I'm like look man she's
your wife you're supposed to love her no
matter what right so it's kind of like
alright but at the end of the day he
also introduces them to the idea that
just because you can use your powers
doesn't necessarily mean you should this
really comes in the form of gambling
debt for Corbeau part of the fun is just
seeing if he can actually went buy it
because the Beyonder uses his powers to
ensure that the horse that Corbeau bet
on actually does win but it's one of
these things where Clara bows like
sometimes the fun of this is the luck of
the draw
not knowing what's gonna happen right
like that's part of the experience
that's part of the enjoyment is just
sort of doing things and kind of getting
a feel for things and so ultimately
after a positive about a day or so poor
Bo's like look man I can't teach you
anything anymore you got to get out
there in the world and you got to make
your own way so from there the Beyonder
started going through all these
different experiences he ends up getting
you know ends up getting like this great
big huge yacht he's surrounded by all
these different women and things like
that
he basically ends up running up on the
kingpin and it's just like you and all
the men around you work for me and
starts using his power to essentially
dominate the Wills of everybody around
the world and they all been to what it
is that he wants then it starts to
extrapolate out well if I can control
the Wills of people then I can control
the Wills of matter I can control the
Wills of molecules and subatomic matter
and so on and so forth there's nothing
that I cannot do right so kind of coming
to this rapid recollection that he can
do pretty much anything he wants to but
the downside to this is that as this
goes on he begins to realize that with
the wills of other people by taking
their will over also comes a really kind
of removal of individualism
what makes them unique what makes them
interesting that begins to go away and
instead he's surrounded by
people where they're all like yes sir
I'll do whatever you want me to sir and
that's that's boy right nobody wants a
yes-man nobody wants anybody who will
lick your boots and so we ends up coming
up on - it's basically fixes her memory
removes the fact that he can control her
mind and then we learned that she
basically found honest work right she
kind of went forward and was like he
looked like you know I have the job as a
server I don't basically you know do my
own thing now
well yeah I'm out there working and I
kind of get stuff and it's cool and so
ultimately he ends up realizing the
necessity and the value of individualism
and then ultimately cast aside his
powers right County allows people to
control themselves yet again allows
people to sort of regain their own
individualism and go from there
and so at that point you end up jumping
over to him basically encountering this
woman who's really kind of considered to
be this there's not really a debutante
but exceedingly popular in terms of the
role she plays in society the socialite
extracting Lea beautiful so on and so
forth and when they have this
conversation she's kind of like you are
fantastic like you please me in ways
that I never imagined before and and so
on and so forth and so it's kind of like
he basically ends up spending the night
with her and then just least right now
she's head over heels for this guy and
so he's kind of looking around at the
world as it exists and says there's so
much dissatisfaction in this life that
people live there's so much unhappiness
here like people are looking to become
something better they're looking to
belong somewhere but at the same time
they're all individual they all have
their own distinct personalities and
different things like that this
inevitably leads to clash so this is
just kind of analyzing all these
different facets and all these different
types of people and and so on and so
forth and so ultimately ends up
revisiting Owen Reese and so what he
asks Owen Reese here is I desire love
right I desire to understand what is
love baby don't hurt me I desire to
understand love what is affection I
don't really understand this mo and
Reese is kind of like man that's a tough
one I can't really explain love to you
all I can really tell you is it love is
one of these things where you care about
a person on a level that's far deeper
than I hope they're okay right it goes
far deeper than that it's one of these
things where they accept you for who you
are you accept them for who they are
though two of you work to make the other
better but the more that you give the
more of it you give back there's a very
difficult concept to explain love like
what's the definition of love and you
could probably find the Webster's
definition you know out there somewhere
but still you know a person-by-person
experience based definition of love
depends on who you're talking to so when
he is up traveling back to Sharon this
this you know socialite here's a finding
out that she basically offed herself you
know when the Beyonder took off because
she felt like she'd never be able to
find anybody better than him so what he
ends up doing is basically reservoir
getting hurt from the dead and then in
turn and then probably one of those one
of the crappiest things ever like he's
like I brought you back to life or she's
like oh my god you came back to me he's
like yeah but like you know I want to
find real love like I don't want what
you have right but like the only reason
why you love me is because of how I make
you feel right that's the only reason
why you love me you don't really love me
you love the way that I make you feel I
just happen to be a part of that what I
desire is a good woman so like he shows
her all these different women and men
and it's like show me which one I should
fall in love with which is really kind
of crappy going to a person who's in
love with you and saying here are the
people that I'm interested in which one
do you think I should date but like if
the friendzone basically and so you get
one of these interesting moments where
he's kind of like okay so the person
that I desire to be in love with is
basically Allison Blair Dazzler and then
he also comments she may very well be
one of the most powerful people to walk
this world which is an interesting thing
although we're never really given a
full-on explanation why instead what he
does is he grabs Alice and he grabs
Dazzler snatches her away and then
basically starts taking her from place
to place you know kind of bounces are
all over these different locations
trying to impress her takes her out into
space to different parts of the galaxy
all in a way to kind of demonstrate
here's here's how I feel about you you
know I really really like you and here's
all these gifts and all that kind of
stuff the classic mistake right like
really showing more of what he can do as
opposed to more of who he is and so the
result of that is she really kind of
seems to reject him in you know
initially and so he kind of begins to
understand what it is that she's looking
for that she wants to understand who he
is and so he basically teleports the two
of them to a mountaintop in Nepal and
they share this really really intimate
moment and initially Allison Blair is
really kind of swept up by it she's kind
of like wow this guy's amazing like he's
taking me everywhere and he's showing me
all these different things and he's
classy and kind and all that kind of
stuff and so he's sort of like hey look
I've got bands and I've got music and
all kinds of things that you can use in
order to keep yourself happy I'll be
right back so he basically just kind of
teleports away he goes to Alpha Flight I
don't really know why and like takes the
bag of shaman which is like whose
disease is really crappy character and
like like freezes daughter which I don't
know why it matters like nobody cares
it's not the flight so the result is
that the really kind of the big takeaway
from this is he takes a ring out of the
bag and then basically ends up running
back to Alice and Blair with the
intention to propose to or at least to
present kind of a trinket a sign of his
affection but ultimately she ends up
rejecting him and the reason why is
because one she doesn't really know him
and two there doesn't really seem to be
much to him and that's kind of the big
important takeaway from this right like
having substance having something to
offer right because when it comes to
relationships and it comes to courting
people it really is marketing 101
you have to find an answer to the
question why are you a person worth
dating right like being a man or a woman
is not good enough right like I'm a guy
that's why you should date me it's like
no that's that's not really good enough
right like that's not okay
like be someone worth dating and that's
kind of where the Beyonder that's that's
kind of what he lacks right because he
seems to kind of like that human
component that ability to understand and
relate to people and so because of that
of course he's rejected by Allison Blair
and then in turn you know he tries to
sort of get her back and there's some of
the Avengers appear out of nowhere and
when that happens a fight breaks out
between the Avengers and the Beyonder
and seemingly in the middle of all that
they kind of seem to get the upper hand
and then of course Dazzler jumps in and
is kind of like stopped right because
the Beyonder sort of controlling and
keeping his powers under check so he's
not really using them to their to their
fullest extent but when he gets Allison
Blair alone and takes her back to the
rock again he basically says I faked the
whole thing right like I faked the whole
scenario so you would understand whether
or not you truly care about me and you
truly miss me right like kind of force
her hand which is sometimes what you
have to do and then the result of that
is that Allison Blair is kind of like
okay let's see where this goes and so
what he does is he gives her cosmic
awareness and it's just way too much for
her to be able to handle or to tolerate
right when that happens like she
basically rejects him right and then she
ends up kind of fleeing ultimately
falling down to the ground and dying and
the resident you know the the Beyonder
resurrects her and it kind of puts her
in a mindset where he dominates her will
and she's in love with him but at the
end of the day he took her freewill away
and so giving it back to her it's just
kind of like you know this isn't gonna
work out but it's not something that can
actually function here instead she kind
of walked away rejected him and that was
essentially the end of that and so
following that the Beyonder kind of goes
about on his own thing kind of wandering
around and sort of looking at his own
life and so on and so forth and it's
really more of him just kind of
pondering his existence what he can and
can't do what he's capable of coming to
terms with everything that's happened so
far and so ultimately he ends up coming
across a young girl named Tabitha Smith
also known as boom boom and this is boom
booms first appears in Marvel Comics
those who guys who were curious at the
moment she's like 13 years old she was
exceedingly young but she also comes
from a really really abusive household
and so for those of you guys who were
reading house and powers of X this is
why Tabitha is so cynical about people
why she has this conversation with the
Beyonder where they're talking about the
nature of friends different things like
that and she holds a very nihilistic
view right in the sense that it's
basically meaningless right that friends
no matter what level they are if they
stay with you long enough they'll
eventually leave right like any friend
like if you have a friend that doesn't
leave you for the rest of their life and
they somebody just didn't live long
enough right that's kind of her a really
cynical and nihilistic view on
friendship and the Beyonder
Jackson this is important because the be
honors not really in a position worse
it's kind of like people are nice and
they do great things you know all that
kind of stuff but he's not really super
cynical either but he's also not naive
he is to a degree but he's gained a lot
of experience over time and so he
understands the difference between a
true truth and a lie and what things can
really be like and how people perceive
things and so on and so forth and so as
a result of that he actually takes off
to his own Beyond realm and really just
sort of hangs out there and uses about
altering the universe and and really
even creating like his own his own
facsimile of Allison Blair inside his
beyond verse but ultimately it's just
not good enough right like it's not
really the same it's actually having
Dazzler the woman who can choose who she
wants to be with and having her choose
him right ladies there's a kind of pride
that comes with that right a kind of
satisfaction that comes with that and
that's what He desires he's kind of you
know beginning to sort of home in and
then hit on this idea of desire and so
following that he ends up grabbing a car
coming across tabatha Smith again and
then takes her to Westchester because
she was on her way to try to find the
quote-unquote fictional x-men in school
that she wasn't really sure if it
actually existed or not but as soon as
she arrives there she says you know like
like literally Rachel summers freaks out
and she's like it's the Beyonder get him
I'm like they all immediately run up on
him and start attacking him and so the
be honored ascends up fleeing right he
doesn't stop peeling off in a car now
again the Beyonder could have destroyed
them with less than a thought right just
a wave of his hand and that would have
been the end of them remember the
beyonders really wanted to understand
humanity and because humanity is for the
most part powerless he wants to either
bring himself down to their level or at
the very least go without his powers in
any real sense and just kind of
experience what it means to live mister
the result is a Tabitha Smith is
actually crushed by the idea that the
beyond are really kind of abandoned her
right it's kind of this continuation of
this ideology that people will always
abandon you this and the fact of the
x-men were nothing like what she thought
they were kind of leaves are gonna
relatively hopeless State so she kind of
calls out to the beyond her and she's
like look come back you know if you
don't come back I'm gonna set off one of
my bombs and I'm gonna blow myself up
we're just kind of crazy and of course
the Beyonder shows up you know before it
goes off he's like you're you're
insanely annoying she's like well I'm 13
years old you know what kind of comes
with a package and I was like look man
if that's what she was willing to do
with 13 years old maybe I should have
left her you know maybe let that run its
natural course but from there what he
ends up doing is basically saying like
I'm tired of this world and his people
on it but almost kinda like this dr.
Manhattan sort of scenario the
motivations are different but he
basically says we're gonna leave this
world and instead we're gonna go to the
world complex which is basically the
headquarters of the Celestials and this
is when you
start getting into the idea of the
cosmic entities and so when he shows up
here because of the fact of the
Celestials really kind of chill right
because when you're a celestial like
when you're a being as old as they are
and you'll be there until the end of the
universe the entire lifespan of humanity
happens like that right it happens in
the blink of an eye and so for them like
they may commit a series of acts and it
happens one after the other after the
other after the other and an exceedingly
fast rate in the same way that you wave
your hand and you tap your foot but for
people who were looking at them it takes
eons for those things to happen right
because they perceive time differently
than the Celestials do and so on and so
forth and so because the Celestials are
usually just kind of sitting around and
and children whatnot there's been this
great big huge tourist trap more or less
has been constructed around them that
people go and they spend money at and
and so on and so forth but what to
beyond her really hits at here is he
starts talking to Tabitha about his role
in the cosmos and he says ever since he
showed up here all the cosmic entities
have been in panic mode they don't know
what to do they don't know how to
respond to him right because Vic hints
they can't destroy him all they can do
is try to figure out what steps they
need to take and that's what all the
cosmic entities are doing Galactus is
doing that Eon is doing that eternity is
doing that but all the cosmic entities
are panicking and they're all trying to
figure out what they're going to do
about to be on earth and so to really
kind of instigate a scenario to show
what the what the Celestials are capable
of the fact that they actually do things
the viana basically shows up and says if
you guys don't come up here and stop me
I'm gonna wipe out the entirety of the
universe and when the when the
Celestials go to make their move he
simply just vats them away with a wave
of his hand and that's really kind of
the end of them of course everything
comes crashing down
Tabitha Smith is horrified of him and of
course he basically ends up taking her
back to the you know back to earth but
following that the Beyonder has this
sort of conflict with the Avengers right
when Tabitha comes back and tells The
Avengers hey look to be honest here and
like things I think are gonna pop off
the Avengers respond and the Beyonder
basically kind of ceases the conflict
and then basically starts walking off
and the big question is what basically
happens with the Beyonder now right like
understanding his place in the cosmos
understanding the full totality of what
he's capable of and what he can do this
turns into the question what will the
Beyonder do next and that's where the
story begins to get cool
okay so we're picking up with the Secret
Wars part two so you're worse -
technically but we're picking up with
the finality of this and as we said in
the last video this portion is what we
started to get into like the good stuff
right so like whatever you guys are
reading online if you're reading the
Wikipedia articles if you're reading
online like you see stuff like the
molecule man vs. Owen Reese things like
that this is where we get into that kind
of stuff but the introduction of the
cosmic entities and and then being
invoked here doesn't happen arbitrarily
instead it's kind of a slow build-up
that sort of leads to that that's kind
of we're not really a slow build-up but
it's a build-up that leads to it and
it's actually pretty smart right because
the idea behind this is that between
issues number five and number six
the Beyonder had kind of undertaken this
task of becoming a champion of life now
in terms of the reason why that actually
comes from a Doctor Strange tie-in and
the way this played out was that
basically the Beyonder had visited
Stephen strange and it kind of talked
about like the nature of roles would
throughout the entirety of the
multiverse right because from this point
going forward there's gonna be
references to the multiverse instead of
the universe because that's the kind of
power we're talking about now why we're
talking about multiversal levels of
power instead of just Universal levels
of power
right so one of the things that that's
really kind of try and ban by the
beyonders he realizes the power of
Stephen strange now one thing to
remember is that Steven strange borrows
the powers of other people that's how
he's able to do what he does but still
he's exceedingly capable and what's even
stranger basically revealed is that
everything in the universe has a role
that it plays right the role of normal
humans out there is to simply enjoy
their lives as best they can before the
time comes when they die but the cosmic
entities pick up roles right the Living
Tribunal is a judge eternity plays the
role of the universe itself given a
physical form Eon represents the the
idea of people keeping themselves alive
basically doing whatever they need to do
in order to sustain their own existence
like all these cosmic entities play all
these different various roles the
Beyonder is an anomaly here he doesn't
have a role and that's because the
Beyonder is not from this multiverse
right I mean it's like a person speaking
English that walks into a country where
people only ever speak Mandarin right
like going into China and so because of
that he doesn't truly have an actual
role here and so what he's been doing is
trying to find a way to fit in but
that's the nature of the Beyonder he's a
square peg in a round hole it just
doesn't quite work and so what he's
doing or at least what he's decided to
do is become essentially a champion of
life and so what this does is it
basically has the Beyonder kind of
building himself up this massive Citadel
so it's kind of something akin to like
the Avengers mansion or stark tower or
something along those lines but while
that goes on you've also got a
journalist by the name
Dave and Dave really stumbles across
this giant building as it's been made by
the Beyonder and then becomes intrigued
by it right now there are a couple of
things that go on
insofar as the Beyonder ends up coming
into contact with power pack those you
guys who never read power pack it was
okay
the power pack was a really really
popular line of comics right you had
Kofi white mane
you had Franklin Richards and you had
like these young superhero kids right so
it was a really really young superhero
team and a lot of kids loved it it was
just never really my thing
but the idea behind this is that with
Dave stumbling across the Citadel of the
Beyonder and the Beyonder returning Dave
really kind of begins asking questions
like what are you what's your purpose
like what's going on here and the
Beyonder makes an argument of him being
a champion of life and when Dave doesn't
really understand what this means
the Beyonder kind of goes on to explain
things and pretty much says what I just
told you about Doctor Strange and the
various roles that people exist to serve
a purpose that everything in the
universe has an order and a structure to
it now I also want to kind of talk about
the cosmic entities for a second right
because we've had this discussion before
but the cosmic entities are Marvel
Comics technically speaking their
ideologies right so like so long as the
universe exists eternity will exist as
well and so long as the universe as time
passes in that universe from the time
that it was created until the time that
it ends infinity will exist as well
infinity doesn't exist at this point in
time but when she's introduced that's
the world that she will play Galactus
consumes various you know planets to
sustain his own existence so on and so
forth but none of the cosmic entities
including Galactus have a true physical
form Galactus is a mirror for whatever
whatever race it looks at him but in his
most pure form Galactus if you were to
see him in his most pure form without
him mirroring you all you would see is a
giant swirling mass of energy and a
giant suit of armor if that's all that
you would see none of them really have a
true physical form the cosmic entities
get their physical forms from the
dimension and manifestations now we
didn't know that until infinity war in
1991 or not 23 whatever was what that
old quasar tie-in from back in the day
basically gave us the existence of
anthropomorphic and basically said that
the cosmic entities whenever they meet
whenever they appear they go to the
dimension of manifestations and they get
a physical form from anthropomorphic and
then they come to the main Marvel
Universe into that or when you see
things like the trial of Adam warlock
during the beginning of infinity war as
part of warlock in the infinity watch
that giant white space where he freaked
out on the Living Tribunal the Living
Tribunal shutdown the Infinity Gauntlet
all that took place inside the dimension
of manifestation so that's kind of the
nature of cosmic entities their
ideologies they can basically receive a
physical form but they
presents something you represent
concepts and that's why they can never
truly be destroyed right if you destroy
the physical form of eternity it would
just get a new body and come back right
that's just exactly what would happen
and so explaining that to Dave Dave kind
of goes on this great huge marketing
ploy you know on behalf of the Beyonder
and really kind of creates this this
circumstance oh well let's see what we
can turn this into right and so what the
Beyonder does it's kind of beginning
going on this quest all around the world
to basically save everybody that he can
from every conflict or every instance
that would kill them right so like a
giant tsunami comes crashing down onto a
city the Beyonder fixes that it kind of
happens over and over and over again and
so what is up happening is that in the
apartment of Owen Reese The Watcher
appears and the watcher basically says
like there's an imbalance here things
are supposed to happen as much as it
sucks
those people were supposed to die in
that tsunami things die it's the natural
course of life and death that's just the
way things work and for somebody to come
along and essentially prevent people
from dying in that way is disrupting the
natural order of things and so there'll
be consequences for this really kind of
pointing to the idea that the Living
Tribunal will choose to intervene but
the reality is the watcher nipped that
in the bud and basically says I can
gather who I can but the reality is that
without your power there's no
conceivable way to stop the Beyonder the
after-effects and the direction this is
gonna go in is gonna really start to
cause problems and raise pandemonium and
so what this does is it leads to a press
conference by the Beyonder when
questions are asked what's he about and
why is he saving all these things and
doing all these these grandiose gestures
and with Dave really kind of speaking up
it's the idea of I'm a champion of life
right to be honor is there to ensure
that people survive and as Dave starts
to go through this he really kind of
makes this sort of metaphysical argument
about how we're not gonna stop fighting
until death is vanquished now the
reality is Dave doesn't actually mean
killing death but the Beyonder takes it
literally he's like we can kill death
like actually now that I think about it
we probably could write like why save
everybody around the world from natural
disasters when we could just make sure
they don't die in the first place no so
what he does is start reaching his hands
out into the cosmos and then start
poking and prodding around and come to
the conclusion yes it can be done like
yes this problem can be solved and so
what it does is it jumps to Mephisto now
Mephisto is kind of on and off with
importance in this part of the story but
he is kind of there right because
Mephisto is one of the hell Lords now
Marvel Comics you have these different
like hell Lord dimensions and then you
have Satan right Satan actually exists
in Marvel Comics but it's one of these
things where a lot of the Hell Lords
claim to be Satan right either they kind
of adopt that mantle under themselves
but as far as we're aware none of them
have actually
encountered the being of Satan now what
al Ewing seems to be doing is actually
presenting this idea the Satan really is
the one below alright he's this nyam
nebadon all-powerful being so kind of
following in that judeo-christian
mindset but regardless of the
circumstance Mephisto hates the idea of
mistress death dying because if mr.
death dies his realm cannot get any more
Souls right because people will be
immortal and so it really sort of
chastises the idea of the Beyonder doing
this but the reality is it he's
powerless in the face of them and so
what isn't happening and one of the
weirdest takes in this story Dave in the
beyond or sitting down at dinner and
they invite mistress death or at least
the Beyonder invites mistress death to
dinner they invite mistress death to the
know hey mistress death you want to grab
dinner sometime I unless let's talk have
a conversation we're our lives billing
what kind of people do we want to be you
know what's our place in the cosmos I'm
gonna kill you like that's really kind
of how this has really got to how this
whole thing unfolds and so what the
Dioner had done was kind of create this
cocktail of sorts right that basically
mistress death would consume and then in
turn it would kill her and so it seems
kind of interesting because with the
power of the Beyonder it would make more
sense to just show up and destroy
mistress death and just be like done
right you're just obliterator but before
she consumes this substance suddenly all
the cosmic entities show up The Living
Tribunal eternity all these folks are
here the Celestials this stranger
they're all here and really sort of
presenting this circumstance of you
cannot kill mistress death right
Mephisto is popping up to you here
Mephisto is saying you can't do that man
it's that's a terrible idea and while he
is a being that delves in dubiousness or
the reality of this is he's telling the
truth that killing mistress death will
create a terrible imbalance in the
universe and so the result of that is
they try to convince the Beyonder to
keep mistress death from consuming this
portion of his power that will destroy
her but at the end of the day he doesn't
care he doesn't listen he's just like
what I'm doing is the right thing to do
and ultimately mistress death consumes
it and she dies now here's the question
a lot of people will look at this and
they will say okay but what about
Pharaohs imperative though when Thanos
imperative Marvel and all them basically
jumped in and and like basically killed
mistress death that Marvel was dying and
so he gathered all the superheroes
together channeled all their power and
killed mistress death and he did that
because the mini angled ones told him
were tricked him into believing it was
the only way to keep himself alive and
that allowed the mini angle wants to
enter the cancerverse and that's how you
ended up with that Thanos imperative
story but at the end of the day people
were asking the question why didn't the
Living Tribunal step in and the reality
is because Marvel wanted it to be that
way
it was just done for the sake of the
story if they kind of
maintain continuity and so far as what
happened before and what's happening now
the Living Tribunal would have stepped
in and said no this is a mystical
imbalance death has to exist therefore
I'm going to return death back to the
way she's supposed to be everything's
gonna go back to normal or whatever the
case is or just by virtue of mistress
death being there everything would go
back to normal
if the continuity aspect of Marvell from
Secret Wars to up to Thanos imperative
have been maintained that's what would
have happened but it didn't because
Marvel wanted to tell a story
it's just how it goes there's not much
you can do about it
Kalen books are not always correct when
it comes to continuity let's kind of
make some fun this kind of make some
interesting right I mean it gives you
guys something to talk about so it must
be worth it but at the end of the day
what is it happening is as soon as this
takes place the molecule man shows up
and all the cosmic entities are like let
this dude pass let this guy pass and let
him talk and it's kind of crazy because
he basically says I want to talk to the
molecule man by myself and he sends all
the cosmic entities away he's just like
get out of here and basically this sends
them all packing and then basically
tells it be on or you've ruined the
purpose of life right the whole basis
behind life is that we don't know how
long we're going to be here and because
we don't know how long we're going to be
here we need to make the most of it
right like it any moment you can walk
out walk outside get hit by a truck and
that's the end of you and because of
that everything that you do matters
right the people's lives you touch the
people that we fall in love with it all
matters but it's all important because
it's this life that we live and we only
get to live at once and so with nobody
being able to die what's the point of
watering plants what's the point of
eating what's the point of doing
anything besides just sitting around all
day and doing nothing they're never
going to die so what's the point of
adventure what's the point of fun you
know it doesn't really have any
relevance to a person who can live
forever
Nestle the Beyonder while he is a
champion of life he's essentially ruined
the value of life for everybody who's
there right and that's kind of the irony
of it right like I've saved all you guys
from dying and now your lives are
meaningless that's basically what the
Beyonder did and so in response to that
you know Dave really kind of chimes in
as well then how do we fix this and the
Beyonder says the only way it can be
done is by basically turning somebody
else into death and that's what he does
he basically turns Dave into death and
Dave goes forward you know when people
are now mortal again so it was a quick
little moment nothing's not the biggest
thing ever but what it does is it really
kind of sin as the Beyonder on a rampage
right because he thought this was his
role right he thought he finally found a
purpose as being a champion of life only
to find out that in trying to fulfill
this purpose he's screwed everything up
in the first place and so he really kind
of goes and takes time to think
there is some stuff that goes on to this
part of the story it's stupid so what
it's gonna kind of skip over it it
doesn't really matter at all but what
you have is this kind of struggle with
Owen Reese right that's kind of the big
big thing to come out of this is the
struggle of Owen Reese and the reason
why is because no one knows what the
Beyonder is going to do now and that's
what makes is so terrifying when the
Beyonder had his mind on a purpose it
was relatively easy to sort of predict
what direction that purpose was gonna go
in right when the Beyonder is like I'm a
champion of life okay well what's the
worst thing he could do he could kill
death anything he does up to that point
good for the most part being maintained
by the molecule man you can kind of be
controlled or reversed or something like
that but when you have the Beyonder sort
of freaking out like this and thinking
like what am I going to do next that's
the big question that's the question of
what's gonna happen it's the thing that
you cannot plan for and so what this
does is it leads to the Beyonder showing
up on the doorstep of Owen Reese and
it's a really cool conversation here
because it's almost kinda like a
psychiatric evaluation right like do
beyonders laying on the couch and he's
talking to Owen Reese and he's talking
about all the subsidies tried to take to
find meaning and value in this life and
to understand what desire is and then he
starts to kind of get angry and the
reason why is because he looks at all of
humanity he looks at everybody on earth
and says yes you guys say that I made
your lives meaningless when I destroyed
misters death but your lives are
meaningless in the first place you guys
have desire because you're incomplete
you want a thing because you believe
that thing will make you complete
because you're incomplete if you guys
are striving to become complete then why
haven't you done it yet why do you wage
war why do you engage in all these
conflicts why do you take life from
other people if life was really as
valuable as you make it out to be then
why do you waste it the way that you do
and so as a result of that Owen doesn't
really know how to answer that question
right it's kind of like it is human
nature that's true but just because
something who is human nature doesn't
make it okay there's ways to fix things
there's ways to get around things but
it's the idea that this is one aspect of
human nature that you can't get past
because people always kind of have this
sort of idea where they look to the sky
and they ask the question what is the
point of all this and no one has an
answer and the reality is anybody who
comes to you and says they have an
answer is this selling something they're
selling a book or they're selling you
there's no real definitive answer there
and then the Beyonder experiences this
kind of frustration because his idea is
there has to be in answer there has to
be an answer to what it is that makes
people who they are and if what I've
done is I've basically experienced this
and I haven't been able to find the
answer to this question then maybe I've
been looking at it the wrong way and so
what he does is he kind of does this
tour of various people right he comes
across
Rachel summers with the power of the
Phoenix force quashes that power right
off the bat and it's just kind of like
you can't really give me any answers you
don't really serve a purpose here he
goes to visit the Incredible Hulk and
this is one of those moments where he
basically analyzes the Incredible Hulk
and then realizes the Incredible Hulk
has infinite strengths right that's
that's really kind of where that came
out at the Incredible Hulk strength is
legitimately infinite that came from
secret Wars issue number eight right so
that's our secret Wars too issue number
eight that's how that comes from but
going from person to person and really
sort of talking to them and trying to
understand them and trying to get a feel
for them doesn't give him anymore
answers and he had before and so in his
anger and in his wrath he also kind of
becomes curious and he says well okay if
all these people are mortal and that's
why they have desire because they're not
gonna live forever and they want to
achieve all these things they want to
find the value of this life therein
before they die I'll make myself
immortal and so where he had basically
eradicated the New Mutants back in New
Mutants issue numbers something I don't
know which one it was what he does is he
constructs a giant device it'll
basically allow him to be reborn in in
mortal form he'll still maintain his
power but he won't be immortal he won't
be indestructible and he really kind of
tests this by basically resurrecting the
New Mutants by kind of bringing them
back and just seeing if it can be done
which he successfully does and then from
there he really kind of jumps into the
machine a couple times and then comes
back out again but he basically sort of
goes on this kind of tear he then turns
around and ghosting in front the
molecule man Owen Reese right because
what he does is he basically says like
you're basically in my way I get that
you're scared as one of these instances
where basically Marvel establishes at
this point in time that the molecule man
is not on par with the Beyonder now in
reality he is that's that's the
important thing to understand the
molecule man is equal to the Beyonder in
power we found that out in secret Wars 3
the unofficial story from Fantastic Four
that basically like they're both two
halves of a cosmic cube that the the
Beyonder was supposed to be one half of
a cosmic u that floated out into the
main model universe and that's a
molecule man Owen Reese is the other
half of the Cosmic Cube that went into
his physical form right so would split
perfectly down the middle that's what
that's what a cubic and all those
different characters explain in that all
that will Fantastic Four story right so
like molecule man is equal to the
Beyonder but it's just one of these
things where he's like my power is not
on par at the time it's written is
probably true but if you take that story
from Fantastic Four into account it's a
mental block or something along those
lines whatever the case is but you get
this kind of crazy situation
where basically the Beyonder shows up
and he's just like I'm going to wipe
everything out of the existence I guess
that's what I'm gonna do if everything
here is incomplete if everything here is
crappy because you have desire
you want to be part of a greater whole
but you don't know how then I will do
that I will wipe everything out of
existence and then I will recreate it
all and I will become the multiverse
I'll become the one above all that's
really what the Dioner seems to indicate
here and so what you have is him
launching this attack against us against
Owen Reese and then and then basically
like volcano Marsha steps in and this is
a really really good red herring because
Marsha jumps in and then basically says
like okay fine if you want to kill him
that's fine but don't hurt me I just
want to live right I'll do anything you
ask I'll do anything that you want me to
but please like just don't kill me like
just let me live
and then she ultimately ends up fleeing
out and in the mind of Owen Reese it's a
massive betrayal she starts referring to
him as things like weak and a worm and
so on and so forth indicating that she
never truly loved him in the first place
why she was just there because he
provided a measure of power to protect
her that she couldn't get anywhere else
and so as a result of that what you end
up learning is that just because it
looks that way does not mean it is that
way the beyond are kind of jealous of
what it was that Owen Reese had that
Owen Reese had this power but didn't
really want to use it that he was you
know seemed to kind of be governed by
fear but still managed to find love is
what made the Beyonder jealous and so as
a result so that Marsha did the only
thing she could do to get to be honored
to go away which was basically abandoned
Owen Reese and in turn because he would
look so weak he would look so vulnerable
to beyond her in some perverse way would
take pity on him and basically leave him
there and then she ends up having to
bail out as well you know it's a cool
gesture to keep Owen Reese alive when
keep it beyond her from basically
killing him but following that the
Beyonder kind of goes out into space and
sort of looks around at everything and
kind of asked the question you know like
what do I want to do here right like how
do I want to erase everything maybe I do
maybe I don't whatever the case is but
ultimately ends up kind of siding with
the idea of making himself mortal before
wiping everything out of existence
within 24 hours and when he does this
when he goes and makes himself immortal
it's an experience that he's never
really endured before and so his first
reaction to being mortal is terrified
he's absolutely scared because it's like
now I can be killed he panics jumps back
in reabsorbs his powers and then goes
back out to being II to be on derp again
and then does the process a second time
and that's really kind of how this works
the idea was to put all of his energy
into this massive machine all this power
into this massive machine into the
device and then basically be reborn in a
physical form and then reabsorb his
power into himself as they're kind of
testing this a couple times and
experiencing what it's like he
ultimately enjoys it and so what this
does is it basically leads to marsha
traveling back to replace where Owen
Reese is at and this is a massive moment
here because what it does is it really
shows a one rescanned of breaking away
from this last
mental block insofar as when he was
talking to Marcia what he basically says
is his initial thought was that she did
bail on him if she says she never saw
anything in him in the first place then
the question was why was she even with
him in the first place why she wouldn't
just arbitrarily peril the Songhai
he's got to be a guy worth having
otherwise why be with him in the first
place and so as a result of that he
begins to kind of put two and two
together sort of look at the pieces and
say yes like there was something about
him that she found to be that she found
to be attractive and she wanted to
pursue a relationship with him but what
he's also found in himself is a lack of
confidence a lack of confidence in his
Worth and a lack of confidence in his
value and so he was looking to Marcia as
a means to confirm his value but with
her basically bailing out and then him
coming to grips with the power that he
possessed and what he was capable of he
essentially came to the realization he
doesn't need her and because he doesn't
need her he's now fully capable of his
powers he's a much better version of
himself now it doesn't mean he doesn't
want her that's kind of a big difference
there right and it's the idea that my
value as a human being is not
intrinsically tied to you you compliment
me as a human being and what you bring
to the table helps to sort of expand and
help me reach newer heights and become
better than the version that I was
before I met you but if it all comes
down to it and we come to an end then
basically this Sun will rise the world
is not going to crack into and the
universe is not going to burn in some
Big Crunch and everything is gonna
restart over again some new cosmos right
the day will go on and coming to that
realization Owen Reese kind of has this
newfound confidence and basically says I
know exactly what we have to do and so
ultimately what is up going on is you
you end up having own Reese who appears
to like all the various superheroes
right who are all basically there and
when the question is asked like what
about the cosmic entities what about
these forces the responses like they're
all terrified they're not going to act
because they know they cannot win at the
end of the day it really all seems to
come down to Owen and so it's kind of
crazy because what a lot of the
superheroes look at him they do see a
guy who was a villain at one point but
the responsible molecule man is don't
waste your time on this right like we've
got bigger fish to fry we've got more
important things to worry about you can
sit here and bicker with me about me
having been a bad guy at one point where
we can save the universe which one's
more important to you and so as a result
of that you end up seeing of course
their combined forces of the Avengers
and the x-men all basically invading the
Citadel of the Beyonder and then you've
got the Owen Reese molecule man this is
a very very huge moment and the reason
why is because the fight between the two
of them and it's very very significant
here right
it basically says the two mightiest
beings in all existence clash and
every creature on every planet in every
dimension feels the multiversal tremors
born of their fury literally their
shockwaves across the multiverse from
this fight the two of them are having
that's how powerful they are at this
moment right now at the time this
story's being written in Marvel Comics
these are the two single most powerful
beings in the entirety of the multiverse
now admittedly a lot of the guys are
probably asking the question what about
the one above all and in truth the one
above all while it was basically
referenced over the course of Marvel
Comics really since the first appearance
of the Living Tribunal it didn't
actually appear until Fantastic Four in
2004 didn't actually see the one above
all until then up until that point it
was just some enigmatic being out there
that supposedly got but we didn't really
know what role it played within the
Marvel multiverse if it was even there
at all right if it even existed it
anymore who really knew there so at the
time the story's being written these are
the two most powerful guys but
understand this like the molecule man's
power does not appear to be on the same
level as the Beyonder at least and with
this story being written and so the
result is that the Beyonder lets off
this massive amount of power that
basically seems to essentially eradicate
most of the superheroes now the reality
is that between the power of the
molecule man Owen Reese as well as Susan
storm using her abilities most of the
superheroes are saved right those
individuals who would have been killed
that could not have been saved by by the
molecule man by virtue of him using some
kind of protective power
we're basically whisked off to a pocket
dimension right that's kind of where
they are at least in order to kind of
keep them protected and keep them safe
but it's one of these things where the B
honor seemed to get the upper hand and
so as a result of that once they
basically arrived back in the beyonders
the base of operations they find that
he's entered the machine and he's
basically being reborn as an infant now
this is where things get really kind of
hairy because what you have are
different superheroes who are kind of
like yes let's kill the Beyonder and
then you have other superheroes who are
like no we shouldn't because he's a baby
now in truth the V honors gonna be
reborn as a mortal and still have all of
its power and still its own attitude and
motivations and probably the same mental
state that it was before he went into
the machine so it's you gotta kill that
baby man like it sucks it as a baby but
like you gotta do what needs to be done
like it's just the way it is right I
mean you know like if you're afraid of
killing deer then don't go hunting
hopefully you'll survive when the
apocalypse comes but at the end of the
day you know molecule man kind of steps
in and says this is what we have to do
like we have to destroy this baby and so
ultimately the molecule man launches a
blast attack that basically destroys the
Machine and unleashes all the power of
the Beyonder and that's one of the kind
of big fears of Reed Richards is when
this power
it's gonna explode in outward direction
and seemingly you know eradicate the
entirety of the multiverse in the blink
of an eye instead what happens is the
exact opposite when all the power begins
to sort of flow out that yes everything
seems to come to an end right but then
suddenly it starts to come back and the
reason for that is because what the
molecule man had done is that when all
this power of the Beyonder came flooding
out the molecule man had ripped open a
portal to the beyond verse and she
handled all that power back through it
again as a result he essentially saved
everybody and of course the baby beyond
her is basically dead and that's how his
character ends right that's how the
story essentially wraps up that what you
get is this sort of kind of epilogue
where basically you see this kind of
power enter back into the beyond verse
and instead of it just being the
Beyonder coalescing in that space what
it does is it sparks a big bang into
beyond verse itself and it starts
creating planets and stars and all kinds
of different stuff now in reality what
Jonathan Hickman did when it came to the
beyonders and Avengers and New Avengers
flies in the face of all of this right
it basically changes this entire
epilogue so if you're curious about how
the beyonders compare now to how they
how they compared at the point of this
story just rich and I just epilogue
didn't happen pretend like it doesn't
exist right I never took place
and the beyond verse is still just this
massive empty white space that houses
all the be all the other beyonders as
well but with that being said guys I
always kind of liked Secret Wars - I
always thought it was fun again
depending on who you talk to something
will say secret Wars one was better
I thought secret Wars one was kind of
boring and that's some cool moments but
it was kind of boring but would that be
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come as
explained and make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later Bruce
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph Ben
john h aj matt in Jeff are John H lean
and mean which is an awesome name Jason
see Austin s Austin a Joey M Steven Z
Austin be Adam K and Genesis 9 16
remember guys you can send me messages
and I'll run off whatever your message
is at the end of the video so long as
there's nothing crazy but if you want to
put a message in there send me an email
Rob at Robert Jefferson calm and if
you're one of these people who get
shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]